hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play mystery the
curiosity of seeking the truth of the
curiosity of being the one who seeks the
truth either way it was a really long
high I think I saw something waving to
me I was looking at the camera I
apologize I missed that picture
jump-scare oh what am I doing here that
is an excellent question ms paint
graffiti on the walls anyway this was a
highly reviewed gaming at a 4.7 on
gamejolt but I've been oh I don't want
to see that
oh goodness gravy I think I know what
that was but I don't want to focus too
much hi again was that the same thing
okay this is gonna turn out delightfully
scary it was highly reviewed so I don't
know what's go
[Music]
okay this place is very scary oh you
poor person oh wow you don't even know
oh my goodness
what have I done is someone thumping is
someone something on the walls oh no
that was just a door closing okay in his
pants why is that guy sleeping upright
the other two are kind of normal I guess
okay anyway let's see what's going on in
here is this a bathroom no it's just a
really grimy nothing there rumbling
you're tumbly do you need me to November
18th 1980 to a new place you came today
and I checked on his situation the
patient seems to be eccentric it's like
I'm starting to feel regret being press
num 0 to hide oh okay that numbs zero
not the numpad but the other no okay but
the other number okay so I'm gonna give
this game the benefit of the doubt
started a kind of song hi what are you
oh it's a light picture I thought
something just like randomly popped up
in front of me there was just a black
box there is someone knocking at the
doors this you know no not me hello
someone knock knock knocking on my door
so what knock knock knocking on my
chamber door do I need to find out who
okay
oh hi you you you okay there you had a
bit of a hunchback going on there and my
vision is still a little wibbly-wobbly
so I had too much to drink before I got
here and I shot like 10 liters of heroin
into my arm apparently I got a key but
to what hello are you still down there
can I get a good look at you do you have
a pretty face I can do that too I can't
do that one but yeah it's the same one
you can't do that it's the exact same
picture oh no are you okay okay buddy
you don't look so good you need you need
like a phoenix glass of water
you okay yeah you'll be fine okay so uh
what am I doing here what am I supposed
to do I got a key I'm assuming those two
the door that was knock knock knocking
so I need to open the knock knack knack
and door to get to where I need to go oh
another informational sign I hope it's
got some important details for me nope
same thing okay so I found the key in
there did I go through here where was
this one locked no this one's just got a
strange noise on the other side of it
well let's carry down this way hmm
honor who built this place I wonder why
they built this place so knock knock
knocking here hello okay
hello okay okay another note good what
does it say the new patient became so
much more safe excuse me I'm trying to
read here
Oh Oh some people just don't have
manners I see how it is new patient
becomes so much more psychotic sigh
conical is not talking
oh he's not talking nor answering our
question the doctor tells me are you
done
you're done that you Thor I told you
come 9th it's not taking you're
answering questions doctor tell me he's
dangerous and has committed a horrible
can't read a horrible press number zero
okay then so what was that all about
don't wanna tell me hello what happened
did someone bash down a door or
something what happened I don't know
what happened wait was that door open
before is that the where I came in this
is one I came in two or this before I
need to go yeah Oh someone doesn't like
the nurse very much I know the feeling
okay so that was important was that
important to me okay
I'm gonna carry on back this way because
I think there was another door over here
that I needed to go to I think anyway
unless it was like a key in that room
that I missed it's pretty dark and
everything look the same so I don't
assume that it was well this one is this
one open this one got open yeah yeah
yeah yeah blood good oh no head I don't
have a friend to talk to I don't have
Wilson anymore boy cast away it would
have been much different if that it was
actually a severed head of one of the
pilots that washed up on shore and he's
just kind of maintained it ah there's a
key
okay no no lag okay lag we're gonna lag
we're gonna lag a lot we're gonna go one
fret this key is so detailed
I got it can I get framerate ho that was
a heavy key my goodness unbelievable
that is unbelievable
my computer my brand-new computer with
an i7 4649 60 X Extreme Edition
processor lag Thank You mo and my
GeForce 780 Ti lag then again I could
probably game blame the game engine for
that one that wasn't necessarily the
game developers fault like I really I
really am trying to give them the
benefit of the doubt here but this is oh
you know I'm gonna keep it open mind I'm
gonna keep an open mind I haven't seen a
monster yet I haven't actually seen
anything yet besides those jump scares
if you could call them that all right
I'm gonna give them the solid benefit of
the doubt I believe in them I think
they're straight and true for what they
want to do no I've already been here ah
here we go wait no what have I got here
I don't think I have okay was that all
he's crying over taking a bath why I
would too if you were in that one yeah
oh wait is this blood new was that blood
there before I don't remember I've been
there I've already been there I'm
assuming this key must be towards
something back in the beginning there
was another hallway that I didn't go
down so maybe maybe there's something
down there maybe there's something good
for me hello maybe I don't look at that
I'm guessing this is some sort of
hospital they're talking about patients
and whatnot oh no oh no those poor guys
okay that was that was it
ah don't forget to save so that you can
return if you died you mean there's
gonna be a thread over here okay you
know what I really want to keep an open
mind on this one but it's not okay a new
patient came into the wait I already
knew that same note I got before me uh
there's a way to save here let me just
do this it's awfully convenient aclinic
can open they're my teeth are beautiful
anyway do you see something in this
million dollar his actions are what I
think it really thinks that there's a
doctor are you
that's horrible you took the Hippocratic
oath how long that's not one okay what
the [ __ ] okay okay
I don't know what you were laughing at I
don't even know what was breaking why
was it just the same looping windows
mashing sound glass smashing why God
that picture
what are you looking at I don't know why
is with the really stupid angry face why
am i sweating okay
this door is locked let's just kind of
get through this please oh cool
don't know what that's about all right
and no speeding thingy hello hi how you
doing can you uh can you uh show me how
to get out of here cuz I'd really like
to find the egg Wow
what did you see something really cool
and you just couldn't keep in your
excitement
this game is trying really really really
hard to do something that's just not
gonna work I don't want to be cruel or
anything obviously it took time to make
but oh wait no the keys over the key I
picked up the key the door was locked
over that way so what was the point of
that one is that one just gonna get
bashed open later and there's gonna I
think just eyelashes going to my eye
randomly Oh what's locked I have a key
what can I do about it something oh okay
that's the first disturbing thing I've
seen in here and that's just cuz I don't
like that hello who's knocking will be
knocked nag nagging alright hang on
okay all right then that was cool I
guess so
so what about that so I like you with
your slightly murderous undertones
you're a cool guy us doctors who
dedicated themselves to healing
I recognize that today a doctor will
come from another hospital they told me
that he's highly experienced and very
skilled I hope that he will be nice to
[Music]
supposed to hold it up to my face okay
wait a minute I don't have a I don't
have a 4-digit coud
[Music]
okay maybe I should save because I have
a feeling that something's gonna try to
kill me now
hello someone there go on tell me what's
going on who's banging who's thumping
all over the place huh anybody know
nobody what about down here there's the
only other door that isn't open it's not
open now I can't open it what do you
want from me I don't have a code well am
I gonna get a code how the hell am I
supposed to die I haven't seen anything
is it is it bad that I'm playing this
game and I'm longing for death that
isn't what the accurate representation
of someone in this situation should do
how do I uh do I have like a collection
of notes or something oh here we go
okay what no okay oh okay no oh there
was another door I remember there was
another door or over there that I needed
to open I think anyway why have you I
have a run button but it's like it's
holy only very slightly better I don't
look at the picture yeah hello I need
some dental work done
oh are you doing how am I supposed to do
this Oh cold - why do I actually uh do I
actually have a code there must be a
code that I need to put in there
oh here's the code
aha one six eight oh four eight six one
that's what it must be because it
wouldn't or less is for one six and now
it's eight six no it didn't start with
one let's try eight six one four let's
try eight six one four cuz that that
might work
oh come on hey okay come on come on 6 6
1 I did it yay yay a door open to what I
have no idea I wasn't one down there oh
did I see it I see it I see it we're
making good progress now we're blazing
through this game now let's hope that
nothing - totally happens actually I'm
gonna save because screw that you're
putting in that coat again I do not want
putting in that code was the scariest
thing in this game so far okay the way
the patient looks at me gets we more
weird more like an evil look there's no
hiding that the fact that the new doctor
is eccentric have I gone crazy or the
hospital itself makes me lose my mind
okay so bunch of
Wow yeah that's what I'm talking about
rahu all right finally some good happen
whoa what the hell oh my god no idea
okay that's some good music I like that
that's good is it royalty-free probably
not oh who cares
Wow what's up where'd he go
that's out what what's happening
what's happening what's happening
[Music]
oh no no no no no how about no okay no I
know no no how about no no no no no no
no no huh no way I gave it a good try I
tried I tried there was that one good
moment it all led up to that I'm not
doing any more cuz no that's why so
anyway this has been mystery curiosity
and seek the truth that was the name of
the title well they can't all be the
cursed forest yeah oh well hope you got
laugh out of it I think I did a bit
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]
you